[Music]
welcome to the reason Roundtable your
weekly Fusion research breakthrough of a
podcast from the magazine of free minds
and free markets I am Matt Welch joined
by Nick Gillespie Peter suterman and
Catherine mangyu Ward happy Edward G
Robinson birthday friends howdy
hey Matt happy Monday let us talk about
the news items last Thursday the Biden
Administration announced that after
nearly 300 days of incarceration in
Russia WNBA star Brittany Greiner was
finally back coming home to the U.S the
results of a negotiated prisoner
exchange with the rooskis we got a lady
athlete who can dunk but had run afoul
of Russian marijuana laws they received
a super villain sounding character named
Victor bout AKA The Merchant of death
who was halfway through a 25-year prison
sentence for conspiracy to murder
Americans the swap was immediately
criticized by Republicans and some
others for overpaying and for uh
potentially privileging Greiner over 52
year old former Marine Paul huelen who
has been in Russia since 2018 on
Espionage charges
uh others have taken the case as an
opportunity to talk about America's own
sometimes harsh Criminal Justice System
Catherine you are a lady who can no
longer dunk uh and also uh no fan of the
carceral state here does the big fan of
the WNBA yes we know can you name a
single team in the WNBA absolutely not
no yeah okay there's even one called The
Liberty oh that's nice see I like
Liberty uh so uh where does the the
grinder swap get you does it get you uh
uh two uh by the way the Russian arms
dealer was leading the league in scoring
leading the WNBA and scoring that uh as
was pointed out by people funnier than
you uh that uh
he can shoot better uh Catherine two
cheers of three uh I'm gonna I'm gonna
give it maybe only like one and a half
cheers I I don't I don't love just the
whole prisoner swap Concept in gen
General I know that this is a
time-honored time-tested way that
Nations interact and it just makes me
want to get rid of Nations frankly
because it's garbage but yeah I mean I
think I am obviously happy to have
um Greiner back I think that
um the fact that the sort of window
dressing of this arrest was Cannabis
possession is
um you know it has definitely
um sharpened some of the heightened some
of the contradictions uh immunitized our
eschaton whichever term you want to use
it's totally ridiculous that she had was
facing such a harsh sentence for such a
minor crime and of course there are many
many people here in the United States
similarly suffering I think that's like
a very reasonable and good thing to
point out
um I want to call a moratorium on
calling people Merchant of death like I
feel like there's a new Merchant of
death every couple of years in the news
and maybe it's just because there's a
lot of death and a lot of people selling
it out there I guess that's a real
possibility but the desire to suddenly
really really care about how bad this
dude is only when the the exchange was
imminent like I've never heard of this
dude before I read the news um and so it
makes me suspicious about whether this
really was a you know tragic undermining
of American National Security
nick uh speaking of National Security
you're old enough to remember the name
Nick down I'm old enough to both
remember and forget Nick Daniel off
until this morning when I uh read up on
him again
he's still alive lives in Paris uh
that's great at least according to
Wikipedia which means it's true uh how
do you rate the Biden performance in a
difficult presidential category uh yeah
I think it's great that uh Brittany
Greiner is back and uh that's kind of
the beginning and end of my interest in
this
um you know whether or not a Russian
Merchant of death as opposed to an
American Merchant of death or a Saudi
Merchant of death got swapped out is
less interesting to me than you know
Greiner was clearly a prop in in a you
know geopolitical battle whereas
somebody like Paul Whalen uh you know
the who's also you know been in prison
for a while it's more complicated
because he's accused of Espionage and
things like that has a military
background Etc I'm not saying he should
necessarily be there but like Griner is
an absolute innocent and I think
whatever we do to get her out is good
Peter our American
Presidents uh in an inherently bad
negotiating position with crappy
countries because we place a higher
value on the lives of our citizens or is
that a bedtime story that we tell
ourselves in order to well it's not a
great negotiating position I mean just
on the face of it right like it's it's
not the position you would wish to be in
necessarily uh like just from a kind of
pure leverage based you know uh calculus
on the other hand it's the right
position to be in because placing a
higher value on life is the right is is
the right thing to do and so in some
ways you put yourself at a at a kind of
a disadvantage just on a sort of pure
raw exercise of kind of foreign policy
power negotiating whatever but in the
end like you you take care of your
people and you value them and you uh and
you do what you can and like that's
that's what matters what matters is that
Greiner is free and back in the United
States and that was it was worth it and
that was the right thing to do I just
want to say though that like uh on The
Merchant of death question like is is
Catherine okay with the 1997 movie
Merchant of death starring Michael Perry
basically it's a it's like a a death
wish so good remake sort of thing almost
certainly not princes by Charlie straws
the fantasy series
like Lord of War which starred Nicholas
Cage as as an international arms dealer
who was understood to be a kind of a
merchant of death if we can bring it
back to Michael parray who's probably
best known of the title role in Eddie
and the Cruisers uh back in my teen mag
days I interviewed Michael Perry and one
of the set questions we would always ask
teen
faves was like what's your best feature
Michael Parra is so epically kind of
intellectually challenged he said my
arms
the tagline for the movie version of
merchant of death should appeal to
Catherine because it's built by humans
programmed by computers the ultimate
killing machine
uh as long as we're going down a Suitor
tangent I think that we can just
conclude all of us that the movies that
should be preemptively canceled are
Merchant Ivory no what I will fight you
another day there's no more Merchant or
Ivory one of them is that so I assume
you canceled like
culture were canceled not canceled like
not making any more of them but maybe
both yeah I think that just you think
they're boring and uh snooty but well am
I correct thank you for interpreting my
my pain my
um uh one uh contribution to uh hostage
discourse is uh that it's hard
um Michael Scott Moore is a friend of
mine uh who was uh kidnapped by Somali
pirates for two and a half years
um he his reaction to the news while
people were making a big big fuss a bit
about it and and I can't believe that
Brittany Greiner has all this privilege
Etc
um he's like hey you know what uh this
stuff's pretty hard it's pretty
complicated we should root for everyone
to come home and maybe uh give each
other a break on how this happens uh I
think there was a couple of years ago
during the
I think it was the Obama Administration
when there was a Prohibition on families
trying to get in and to uh pay uh
ransoms to either Somali pirates or the
Iranian regime because there's been a
series of prisoners still is
namazi I think is still uh in Iran
um uh held a captive there and the
prohibition on Americans uh being able
to pay Ransom don't like that we should
be able to free to to do what we want
with uh with our own privacy especially
when you're not dealing with State
actors
yeah uh and I mean the I the idea that
the government knows better about like
oh you better not incentivize
negotiating with terrorists because we
never do that except in absolutely every
single Administration
um so yeah it's complicated we should
give each other a break and maybe not
choose uh each and every instance of
things like this to play stupid
two-party politics but we do uh and
that's the way we go uh we go through
life all right let's move on to the
subject that our stupid subcategory of
humans
you're just thrown at the Playbook and
you're going to talk about Air Bud
no
so Twitter files uh since the last time
we gathered around this uh
metaphorically circular table there have
been at least three agonizingly long and
increasingly indecipherable uh Twitter
threads showing internal documents at
the social media company regarding uh
how and when to limit the reach of or
sometimes straight up ban various uh
would-be users of the service the first
of those three from Barry Weiss showed
such behind the scenes classification
categories as and these are verbatim
quotes here Trends Blacklist
they use the word Blacklist and search
Blacklist and do not amplify
the second uh tranche of Twitter files
coming again from Matt taibi got into
the coordination between the between
Twitter and the FBI in the run-up to
permanently banning Donald Trump
um and the third by Michael
schellenberger uh detailed the various
ad hoc uh censorship and rationales
thereof exercised after the January 6th
riots on Capitol Hill in the meantime
new Twitter CEO and former Catherine
manga Ward boyfriend Elon Musk has been
busy making himself the main character
of his own company through a series of
edge lordy rufo-tastic tweets like the
woke mind virus is either defeated or
Nothing Else Matters Deep Thoughts space
dude uh in the spirit of tldr which for
you fellow olds means too long didn't
read I think
um let's go around the table and each
poll one thing that we've learned of
Interest since last week via these
Twitter files Catherine do you want to
lead us off yeah I think um the Barry
Weiss Twitter file was the best one in
the sense that it had the uh the kind of
most substantive evidence of
um government interference here which is
something that I'm always looking out
for
um you know there really was a bunch of
back and forth between CDC and Twitter
execs about what is and isn't allowed on
Twitter don't love that but I mostly
think that the lesson here is just it's
still management and not law for the
most part like the shellenberger Twitter
files in particular it's Twitter execs
just making up stuff as they go along
um they kind of want to project the aura
of having a rule-based system while
actually operating on an outcomes based
system
um partially because one of the outcomes
they wanted was to be perceived as
having a rule-based system
um like the Supreme Court same critique
that I leveled at original lists last
week and some people did not enjoy that
I got some emails about it
um you know this is this is a thing that
that happens in a lot of different areas
it's not surprising to see that it
happened inside Twitter
um it sure does seem chaotic and messy
and so uh the lesson for me was like
don't don't be like Twitter
um but actually the critique was not
leveled against original specifically
nor am I leveling it against Twitter
specifically but humans this is how
people are
um and uh one one does not like to see
it but this is what is happening
underneath the hood in almost every
organization institution and ideology
Peter you uh have characterized this in
internal slack channels as a something
Burger why
well I do think we have seen evidence
that uh senior people at Twitter were
conferring with law enforcement with
federal law enforcement officials with
the FBI and with DHS
um it's it's a little bit unclear
exactly what was going on but there are
references to weekly and monthly
meetings with um with senior law
enforcement officials now that doesn't
mean that the senior law enforcement
officials were necessarily setting
policy
um but it's there's a there's a very
sort of funny and telling little
Exchange
in which one Twitter staffer is sort of
uncomfortable with describing their
method for determ making determinations
about how all of these you know
judgments uh which accounts are going to
be uh sort of blocked or restricted or
whatever and he's like well do we really
want to call DHS and the FBI experts do
we really want to like say that that's
who we're talking to all the time I'm
paraphrasing here but that's the gist of
it and they ended up just calling those
folks partners
right and so they're making these
decisions in in consultation with
Partners right who are out there the
partners turn out to be
um senior law enforcement officials I
think that the the bigger takeaway for
me the more General one is well first
just what I said last week that threads
are bad and articles are good because
these things are just so hard to follow
at this point the threads keep breaking
it's just very difficult to like quickly
go through and see see the information
but
but that these guys were acting as
editors
and they were acting they were making
decisions based on kind of the
information they had they were like in
some ways kind of kind of experts in in
the field of like political discourse in
the way that that editors are
um but they were also just Googling
stuff sometimes I mean there's a there's
a screenshot in which one of the senior
folks is like actually that's true and
then just like posts an NPR link like in
in the space of like a couple of minutes
because that that that's how we know
stuff is true and it is
there's no there's not going to be a way
for a company like this to definitively
determine oh this is the truth and this
isn't the truth and we know this uh and
we don't know that and you can and like
and there's just there's inevitably
going to be editorial judgment exercised
in the process of doing that and that's
not necessarily even a bad thing it's
also not necessarily a good thing it's
just an inevitability I mean in in the
same way that um that like any news
organization that makes choices about
how to present information right you're
selecting a little bit from a press
release or from a speech or you're
printing the whole thing either way
you're making a choice and you're acting
as an editor and that's what these folks
were doing in real time with uh arguably
the most influential platform for kind
of journalistic and political speech at
least in the United States and maybe
um in the western world
Nick you're a fan of transparency uh and
also terrified of transgender uh where
do you and uh but uh transgender boredom
is
of course the Neil Young album called
trans
featuring his 13-minute self-plagiarism
like in Inca which is essentially Cortez
the Killer set in a different murderous
Native American or meso-american Empire
can't believe how much I hate you guys
sometimes yeah would you call anyone
involved in that a merchant of death
uh you know I don't I think they were
giving it away for free in the Incan
Empire so it's not really Merchant
um on the topic Nick which is
[Laughter]
just I'm gonna make I'm gonna make you
think of it no I know I went out loud
yeah about Twitter and the Twitter files
yeah uh which is rapidly I think there
have been as many Twitter file threads
as there are seasons of Doctor Who or
certainly by the time this comes out in
a couple hours uh
the uh I love the I love seeing the
internal decision-making apparatus
because it as you know both uh Peter and
Catherine have said in uh different ways
it's clearly results based you know it's
results oriented
um the you know the the big question in
a lot of ways I and I guess we'll still
see some of this of like why did Trump
get a lifetime ban
um you know and that's still to come out
and why did the post story get banned
the way that it did because I think the
New York Post uh Hunter Biden sorry
because a lot of people uh you know and
I retweeted Robbie suave's I I thought
of an excellent Roundup on uh the
Twitter files number two
um uh which was Barry Weiss's uh talking
about The Blacklist and things like that
a lot of people were like look you know
Twitter said they were doing this all
along so shut the [ __ ] up like why
should you be surprised that Twitter was
de-emphasizing people and clamping down
and blah blah blah and it's like when
you look at the specific examples and I
think the you know the material
including uh are related to Jay
bhattacharya the Stanford Medical uh uh
faculty member an economist a public
health guy it's really interesting
because like you don't there was no way
of knowing whether or not you were being
put on a blacklist or not and looking at
the specifics of that decision making or
that it got done is really interesting
and the one thing and this is something
we should hold Elon Musk to because we
need to be reading all of these through
the fact that Elon Musk is leaking
documents about a company that he owns
but before he took over so he you know
is all of this is interested material
and we have to be very critical in
reading it in that way it doesn't mean
it's wrong it doesn't mean it's not
important or interesting but you know we
we have to keep that on musk over the
weekend said that he was working on
generating a Twitter tool that will
allow people to know if they are being
de-amplified or whatever you want to
call it and to appeal those decisions
and that's the tool I think that would
be great and I would love to see happen
the thing that I would like to see here
that we haven't seen
is uh is
totalizing data comprehensive data that
you know not necessarily sort of what
we've seen everything everything we have
seen so far is essentially an anecdote
right we have seen a bunch of
screenshots stories about this you know
this meeting happening or this decision
happening with this account but what we
haven't seen is anything like oh here's
just a chart of how many people are
being blocked in this way and for what
reasons over for what amount of time we
don't have any sort of sense of the
scale of it or the you know how
comprehensive how frequent this sort of
thing was and I think that that's
notable it doesn't necessarily mean that
that they're trying to hide that
information from us but it would put
what we are seeing in context in a way
that we we're just not able to right now
uh in fact Peter we're building on what
you and Nick both just said
um Jay bhattacharya uh over the weekend
stop it just stop scoffing in the middle
of me pronouncing people's names
you know
Jay batashuria uh went into Twitter just
call him he's the real Dr Jeff uh went
into the Twitter headquarters and had a
look at his own history
and concluded uh you know at the behest
of Elon Musk came on in and concluded
that
um he was at least uh throttled
blacklisted from the outset of him
joining uh Twitter and his theory was
that it was because his pinned uh tweet
or information
um uh was a link to the Great Barrington
declaration the famous in some circles I
guess notorious in the circles of Dr
Anthony fauci continues to be resigning
um uh notorious declaration by a bunch
of Public Health types who simply said
uh way back when that hey maybe we
should try to protect the olds and let
the non-olds and non-six uh get on with
their lives
um and for that to be a reason if it was
indeed the reason for him to be
blacklisted is um is terrible and it
says something bad about the censorious
Instinct that we've seen not just on
Twitter uh but uh again to Catherine's
point the after all it's you and me
problem
which is that people have this
sensorious Instinct and used it not just
uh in in governments not just in uh on
social media but even in kind of
professional research
um uh John Tierney Catherine's former
boss and friend of the podcast and
reason uh wrote a pretty uh Great Piece
a couple of years ago just documenting
all the different ways the research was
stifled
um and and researchers who came up with
different ideas about the prevailing
wisdom about covid were punished like
they were sanctioned and they had a hard
time getting their research published
that's all a dark chapter in where in a
dark Glimpse in where we are kind of
intellectually in this country anyways
Catherine I'm interested in a thing that
Elon Musk has said but also Glenn
greenwalda said Matt taibi has said Tom
Fenton has said so it must be true which
is that the Twitter files show that
there has been quote election
interference unquote in uh the 2020
election uh I am a literalist at heart
and this makes me mad
um uh can you talk me down from that or
is that as uh awful as I imagine it to
be no let's be mad I think
um I think that uh you know the idea
that
um contributing to and in some cases
um you know squelching and distorting
discourse around topics that have
political relevance is not the same
thing as election interference
um and that uh maintaining those
distinctions is important not least
because we don't want to empower
um sitting officials to call election
interference on their political foes
that's uh you know that's a really
really dangerous precedent and
um and so we don't want slippage with
that terminology it's not a question of
like well actually elections are really
complicated things in the modern era and
so maybe everything is election
interference no absolutely not
um we need to we need to keep that
category clear because the powerful will
exploit uncertainty around that
terminology to make elections less for
free to actually interfere with
elections I don't think Twitter did the
right thing to
um throttle body charia I don't think
Twitter did the right thing to throttle
the New York Post story
but I also don't think that is the same
thing as stuffing a ballot box or you
know sending out a flyer telling people
the wrong election day and uh preserving
the distinction between those two types
of behaviors is really important
Peter one questioned that all of this
and I know you can't say begs because of
other literalists but a question that it
suggests
um raises thank you
um is
does Twitter actually matter man uh
which is to say everyone's talking about
it etc etc uh but is that we have seen
uh in the past people don't win
elections by catering to Twitter uh
Twitter is an elite uh discourse sandbox
um uh where people act like
three-year-olds for the most part
um what is your sense of the actual heft
and comparative uh uh importance of
Twitter in this modern world of ours
I think it's exactly what you said it's
an elite discourse sandbox and on the
one hand that makes it quite important
because for when it comes to to politics
when it comes to big business when it
comes to the decisions uh that shape a
lot of people's lives they are um you
know often made by people who we would
consider you know very broadly speaking
Elites and in particular journalists and
people who deal in knowledge uh for
their business all day long
um you just go into any Newsroom whether
it's a small non-profit like reason
whether it's a big you know for-profit
Newsroom like the Wall Street Journal or
the New York Times and you will see a
huge huge number of screens in which
Twitter is open either in the background
or as the main thing it is it's not true
of every journalist but it is simply
true that many many journalists live on
Twitter
which explains some of the other
Dynamics here like it's sort of a place
and a polity uh it's also like a bar and
a club and a hangout space and so that's
why people are mad that Elon took over
right like Elon basically uh bought the
the bar that all the journalists hang
out at all day and then made himself
king of it and it's just like no no the
Jameson special we're not doing that
anymore now it's only it's only
limoncello shots and people are mad
because they like the Germans they like
the Jameson special
so obviously it's important where
journalists where uh you know government
officials um hang out right and so this
is a big thing in the White House the
Biden White House has on the one hand
decided to pay less attention to Twitter
than the Trump White House did uh on the
other hand Ron Clane the chief of staff
uh to to President Biden appears to
spend all day on Twitter just follow his
feed and you will see just tweets
constantly constantly constantly
throughout the day and he's the chief of
staff to the president of the United
States and so it matters in that way but
Twitter is not a a force for mass
culture outside of the the fact that it
influences the people who create mass
culture and the discourse it's not
something that most people uh spend a
lot of time on it has a much smaller
footprint than other social media
companies even something like Facebook
which is in Decline and so on the one
hand yes and of obviously matters
because
journalists and political actors and
information workers matter a lot to our
discourse and on the other hand
you just asked a hundred random people
in any City that wasn't DC New York LA
or San Francisco uh what did you think
about what happened on Twitter today
they would be like what
whereas if you went to my dog park in my
middle class DC neighborhood I'd ask
people what did you think about what
happened on Twitter today well you
wouldn't even need to ask them because
when I go to the dog park they're so
they're all sit around watch their dogs
play talking about Twitter I'm not
making this up that's what it's like to
live here Catherine did I just hear a
great story assignment for reason TV
maybe yeah I'm still hung up on the idea
of what it would be like if the entire
political and journalistic class just
started drinking like a ton of
Limoncello
I want to see one of those paintings you
know where the old democratic presidents
or republican presidents are playing
pool or horseshoes but it's the bar that
Peter yeah imagined yeah no I mean this
is and in fact even
like sometimes I have this uh you know
this phenomenon where I will like come
home at the end of the day and talk to
my my husband who is not in
is not in journalism and it's not in
government he's like not part of those
worlds and uh I will start to like
relate to him what happened on Twitter
today and like about half the time I'm
like yeah this is interesting and
important and about half the time I get
a quarter of the way in and I'm like
actually you know what
never mind
and I think that's about you know right
like so where did where did Bean dad
fall oh on the on the never mind versus
actually your dad started a national
conversation I've got the full detail
treatment but that is because you know
we're in the phase of life where we're
still trying to decide whether or not to
be being dead so that was a more
practical application I'll tell you this
if we lived in a world without cans
being Dad wouldn't need to exist you
know or if they were all pole tops I
think one of the more interesting
questions and this will go to whether or
not Elon Musk is just a self-serving
sack of [ __ ] or a really you know tough
and interesting boss who might bring
Twitter into the next iteration of
transparency is seeing
um you know whether or not he releases
more information about how the Trump
Administration pressured Twitter uh
because there's some mentions of that
and some kind of you know uh uh
ruminations about that are premonitions
of that and some of the stuff that's
been released but it's not just you know
it wasn't just Obama and it wasn't just
Biden who was trying to work the refs at
Twitter and we know that uh everybody
knows this that uh Donald Trump and the
people around him are the biggest
[ __ ] crybabies in the world every
time anything gets said that is an 150
percent you know uncritically positive
about uh Trump you would get an earful
and I would like to see that I would
like to see and what kind of agencies
what kind of deep State people were
working the refs during the Trump years
and things like that but I think that
would be really helpful all right let's
leave our limoncello bar sandbox and uh
get here quickly to our listener email
of the week in a moment but first I
wanted to let you know that the FTC
apparently requires me to read before
continuing on with an advertisement the
phrase this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp ain't compliance Grand
friends we all know probably too well
that the holiday season can be one
logistical and emotional Minefield after
another family travel shopping covet
anxiety shorter days colder nights
broken kneecaps sure you could try
blundering through the darkness like I
do every day or maybe this year get
yourself and your brain a guide to help
you navigate the tricky bits that's
where better help the world's largest
therapy service comes in betterhelp has
matched three million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists it's an affordable service
100 percent online like Peter and super
flexible if you don't like your first
match swap them out for another until
you find the right fit listeners who act
now can get 10 off their first month
just go to betterhelp.com Roundtable
fill out a brief questionnaire and find
your guide through the looming Darkness
that's better halp like prayer
go there today you'll be glad you did
all right reminder to send your out loud
readable queries to Roundtable at
reason.com this one which if I read the
whole thing would double the length of
this podcast comes from Jay Linton who
after detailing the racer thin electoral
margins of various contests rights
should libertarian that was a
capitalized L candidates throw the
election one way or the other in
exchange for a public pledge by one or
two large party candidates for example
adopting an official public policy and
or naming them to a cabinet position
obviously the candidate couldn't Force
voters to cooperate but with the large
number of Libertarians in excess of the
number needed suggest that enough would
go along with the scheme to make it work
and of course no one could prove that it
didn't what do you think Nick you've
been covering the machinations of the
libertarian party this year uh what say
you
foreign
like what uh Chase Oliver uh the
libertarian candidate for Senate in
Georgia did after a runoff after he
forced a runoff by more than covering
the spread between uh uh Rafael Warnock
and um Herschel Walker uh keeping them
from getting a clear majority uh he
tried to have a conversation with each
of them publicly and then he would make
a decision of which uh you know who he
would suggest or advise his uh voters to
go for in the runoff election I think
that makes sense I think if you do it in
a very kind of clear-cut uh way with
real hardcore specifics and Promises
from a candidate that makes a certain
amount of sense I think what Mark Victor
the Senate candidate the lp Senate
candidate in Arizona did where he threw
in the towel well before the general
election and endorsed Blake Masters was
doubly wrong if you I mean if you're a
candidate and you throw in the towel
before the election you are really
undermining the whole legitimacy or the
the reason for a party to exist so that
was bad and then the discussion he had
with Blake Masters was essentially black
Master said you know for a while in high
school I used uh Human Action to keep up
one leg of the table in my lab in high
school so uh Victor was like yeah you
ought to vote for a guy who like a
couple of weeks before had said
libertarianism doesn't work who is
against immigration who is against free
trade agreements among many other things
and talks about using the state as a
tool of moral instruction and correction
so there's a good way to do this and a
bad way to do this Catherine um is uh
having uh trying to extract a pledge
from a major Party candidate if you are
a Libertarian or some other minor Party
candidate uh even less uh useful than
voting yeah that was absolutely what I
focused on in this question so I
appreciate that you know me so well
um why in the world would you trust the
promises of major party politicians they
are stinky Liars who will betray you and
that's what's gonna happen
hey Biden delivered most of what he's
promised he's certainly working at it
promises man I think that there is in
fact political science research that
suggests that politicians do feel in
some sense Bound by their promises and
try to deliver on them even if they
don't necessarily always I think that of
all the promises that politicians might
in fact feel Bound by uh one made to an
LP candidate who then does or doesn't
deliver perhaps as many as 60 of the lp
vote since as we know from other social
scientific literature the libertarian
vote does not always swing one way uh
those people tend to be divided I would
also just guess that when um LP
candidates throw their their support
behind a major Party candidate that more
so even than other political minorities
Libertarians are like screw you you're
not my real dad and you can't tell me
what to do
um so I don't know how many votes they
have to command
um
I just I just don't think this is the
way like I understand why this is a
question that someone would ask and it's
it's a reasonable enough question to ask
I think it is what it betrays is sort of
a wishing a dream that our system was
more like so many other systems where
there is there are more than two parties
and that then the parties can form
coalitions unfortunately that is not
what our system is like and so now and
always I think that it makes much more
sense to focus on policy and not
electoral politics
Peter you live in a Libertarian dog park
would say you
yeah I mean
it depends it depends on the candidate
it depends on the pledge does it depend
and the circumstances sure the
candidates he's talking about he's not
talking about like you well like
somebody who got the candidate the lp
the candidate the lp candidate would be
making a deal with and what they would
be promising but in the main I think the
answer is no uh this is not a deal that
is obviously worth making at least most
of the time um if only because I think
there's a real risk of undermining
what is in some ways the main point or
at least a main point of running as a
capital l libertarian isn't isn't the
point of running as a as an LP candidate
to carve out space for something that is
truly different something that is not
really even compatible with two-party uh
you know sort of binary politics
Orthodoxy as we know it I I think the
like if you're gonna run as a third
party then you should
have you should have a sense of yourself
as being distinct enough that well you
know that the other parties aren't the
the reason you're our third parties the
other parties aren't good enough and
what you say is well if they just did
this one thing they would be then
doesn't that mean that in some sense
you're okay enough with that with that
party and with its platform
um if like in an i the lp has many many
problems these days but in an ideal
world it is truly distinct from uh from
Republican party and the Democratic
party and this uh this method of sort of
trading I think undermines that
distinctness which is part of the sort
of at least theoretical value of having
a third party I think that's true but
then you do have the runoff example that
I gave as well as in uh a state like
California
where only the top two people in an Open
Primary go on to the final election and
if you had an election where it's within
spitting distance and the libertarian
Party candidate has done well
they I think they should absolutely
apply themselves and and try to Stage a
discussion about a couple of issues that
are very important and force the major
parties to kind of reckon with you know
the idea that there is a Libertarian
vote out there and that's why I said it
depends on the candidate and on the
pledge and if you could get something
substantial out of it and actually get
that thing rather than just get a
campaign Trail promise that didn't pay
off and was almost certainly not going
to pay off and was you know small to
begin with then maybe I could see a
circumstance in which I would think
that's not a bad idea I just think in
the main it's not going to work out very
you think about stuff like the you know
the tax pledges right which like they
weren't irrelevant but when it came time
to Chuck those over the side of the boat
for political expediency
people did so without a blink of an eye
and so I think you know I think
concessions to get an appointment
somewhere are probably the most
promising in some ways you know make
make me your make me your Secretary of
Transportation or whatever
um I don't see at least at the moment in
our political landscape any LP
candidates that are in a place to wield
enough power to get a really substantial
concession like that
my answer to the question is
um similar to Nyx which is to say never
do this if you're on the ballot and
should there be a circumstance that the
design of the election makes it so that
you're not on the ballot
um uh through otherwise no fault of your
own
um then maybe
um uh if you can like try to foreground
the issue that you were running on and
you can get uh some discussion of it
that that could be a worthwhile exercise
with the strong caveat of a phrase that
OG political blogger and occasional Ann
Coulter arm candy uh Mickey house used
to use uh cheap dates which is to say
there are people who are just looking
for a reason to throw their support
behind someone because they just kind of
like them
um so if if he or she uh mentions the
one author that they might have read or
whatever
um you know there was uh we had a piece
and I've been blanking on who wrote it
for us
um uh not long after Obama got elected
he was supposed to be you know the most
transparent Administration in history
and it was uh amazing how many
transparency type of organizations were
total cheap dates when it came to Obama
he just said those words and they
thought they won and they started giving
him all the awards for being like
sunshine dude of the year and stuff that
were all like uh aspirational preemptive
or congratulating themselves for
extracting that really important pledge
that he then did nothing and I mean the
opposite of something to do anything
about
um so don't be a cheap date
um if if you're in that unusual position
the George runoff position uh is an
unusual law and the California top two
thing is terrible passed in the name of
of helping third parties which it
obviously has helped quash so it's a
rare case
um I think third parties should run uh
elections and candidates and that
there's way more libertarian voters to
Catherine's Point than there are members
of the party and don't don't assume that
you uh that you have those people in the
palm of your hand and they can be
deployed however you decide to uh at the
last minute of a two-party election and
that's the memo um do we have time for a
lightning round let's do a quick
lightning round
um uh uh last week Catherine's uh sexy
Arizona girlfriend uh Kirsten Cinema
Senator announced that she and her
sartorial Splendor uh would be leaving
the Democratic party to become an
independent this will not have any huge
implications on the Democrat slim
majority in the world's allegedly
greatest deliberative body as she will
continue to caucus on team Dem but it
did make a lot of people really big mad
um so uh Catherine does she still uh
retain your affections yeah I mean she's
Amplified them she made me big happy
obviously uh I I read um some years back
a book that was pretty good about this
this trend of um kind of the growth of
people identify as Independence and so
it's really interesting to see that play
out here
um I also really really enjoyed the
irony of Bernie Sanders's reaction to
her announcement which was basically
like get her ass like he was furious at
her and
um and was like I would strongly
consider backing a challenger to her I
mean it's like Bernie baby like do you
not can you not see the letter next to
your name like I you know I get it like
there's it he's being philosophically
consistent to say I back Progressive
candidates but it you know give a girl a
break like sometimes you've got to be an
independent because your party goes one
way and you go the other and Bernie of
all people should appreciate that
um I uh you know I continue to have only
optimism about Arizona just general I
mean that kind of the little square
States out there generally um seem to
produce some of America's better
politics and
um and I'm delighted that
um that my sexy arizonian girlfriend is
now an independent
uh Nick you've been invoked we'll see
uh well I do think that uh we were right
Matt in the Declaration of Independence
how libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America that it's just
Independence everywhere I mean I don't
know about you everywhere I look I just
see a growth in Independence but uh it's
always great uh whenever a uh you know
whenever a politician disaffiliates with
a major party uh I would prefer that
they become Libertarians even though I'm
not a member of the party but uh putting
that eye there you know that's a pronoun
I can get behind man a political thing
you mean your pronoun isn't prosecute
fouchy I'm so ready for the pronoun
discourse to be over I don't think
that's a that's a gerund maybe or
something I don't know an adverb uh
Peter how does uh a cinema split your
infinitive
I'm just glad that there will be more
opportunities to reference one of the
greatest books I've ever read the
Declaration of Independence uh no I
actually had a a real question for you
which is uh point out though the the
real problem with Cinema is is it
Kristen or Kirsten I think it's you know
I mean enough already
that's even worse that's like over yeah
yeah I mean just I all hard C names
should just be Kathy all right Catherine
Kathy you know uh to me the question is
uh is is whether
it's
Cinema
or film
cinema or movies we're just gonna start
calling her Kristen film
Kristen film uh no but Peter does this
not
um uh uh does she then uh suck some of
the hate from your sexy West Virginia
boyfriend Joe manchin uh or how does
this uh no thank you how does this
phrasing what what
nothing carry on yeah uh something
something Joe manchin Peter go
it depends on how she ends up using her
vote but um I think it's quite possible
she is someone who has already courted
the hate of the partisans uh in the
Democratic party uh just by refusing to
sort of automatically sign on to things
that Joe Biden wants her to sign on to
and this suggests that she is going to
continue doing that if so then I assume
that the people who's sort of driving
theory of politics is democrats should
do stuff that Democrats want to do
determined by top Democrats
Cinema
film
movie lady she doesn't want to she
doesn't seem particularly inclined to uh
to approach politics that way and uh you
know while I'm certain that I will
disagree with many of her votes and many
of her sort of policy preferences uh I I
think a less partisan less Party
politics
driven way of of approaching
American politics is good and I'm glad
to see it um gaining prominence if we
may it's also worth pointing out that
you know every a lot of the discourse
around this was that this was a
fantastic strategic move by her to kind
of Stave off a Democratic primary
challenge
um but which may or may not be true but
you know the Republican party in Arizona
is batshit crazy I mean they are you
know they are still behind Carrie Lake
who is nuts
um and is you know has little to no
reality testing so it remains to be seen
how this affects the Republican party in
Arizona which could have could have
nominated Doug Ducey one of the most
popular and successful two-term
Governors anywhere but in Arizona
history he would have won against Mark
Kelly you know easily and instead
they're stuck with this now and the
Republican Party may go nuts after
Cinema or film or whatever we want to
call her the Big K
and that could shake things up in a way
that uh is unpredictable and kind of
interesting
um all right let's go to our end of
podcast what we have been consuming in
the cultural Arena Catherine do you want
to lead us off yeah I am reading Wolf
Hall uh which is uh the first of a
Trilogy by Hillary mantel I don't know
why I'm so late to these books which are
pretty clearly
um on brand for me
um there is a they came out I think in
2010 or the first one did
um there's a television adaptation that
is relatively recent maybe actually 2009
uh there's a television adaptation
that's pretty recent so it kind of
popped back up into the cultural
discourse a couple people recommended
them to me
um in my uh still also mental recently
died quite unexpectedly yeah so there's
there's kind of been a little bit of a
convergence they they came up as
suggestions for money
uh recommendations but um they're
they're
um you know they're the story of kind of
Court Intrigue Thomas Cromwell um really
really gorgeously written I'm like the
10 000th person to note this but uh
English is kind of a cool language and
these books are doing something very
interesting with English uh and
um and just like really really
delightful and immersive to read
um recommend them for your Christmas
break if you have not already consume
them I have not yet watched the series
so I can't speak to that but it also got
good reviews
I will just note for the record
uh that when Catherine came over and saw
Wolf Hall on my shelf like on my reading
stack shelf she was like really dude are
you gonna you're actually gonna do that
this was about three months ago I just
and now she's doing it I had the wrong
impression of it you know sometimes you
just get like I think I must have seen
one advertisement for the series uh and
I just thought I thought the wrong thing
about these books and I guess that's a
lesson to not always
um you know judge my first appearances
what are the stakes for Liberty in the
court intrigger is that a uh is that a
uh a theme is somebody more pro-liberty
or anti-liberty and I would not say that
uh the at least the first in the series
lends itself to reading through much of
a uh a Libertarian lens except for
insofar as it is a is a portrait of a
person grasping for power
um and not a a entirely flattering one
Nick you're a doctor of English
literature what did you consume yes yes
I actually American literature whatever
it's it's written in English literature
has best understood as a footnote to
American Literature
um
yeah so uh I answered the question
yeah so I uh I finished uh season two of
White Lotus which I highly recommend it
may come back to but I'm going to talk
about Ozzy wins Inner Circle which is a
magic uh show that is currently in New
York City uh and it's reasonably priced
which is a strange thing to say about
anything in New York City but Ozzy wind
is an israeli-born magician who has
worked with people like Penn and Teller
and David Blaine and he's a master of
kind of close-up card magic which I'm
not that big a magician fan I mean I I
like Jiffy Pop and the amazing
Blackstone or whoever did that ad
um but this is a phenomenal show and
it's a great experience which is one of
the things that I've been into post
covid and in terms of Art in general
there's a real turn to immersive art or
experiential art and the way that wind
does this they created this tiny theater
that's really cramped apparently they
had to that's on the NYU campus and they
had to get special uh kind of variances
to build a theater in this way because
you're really close up on each other
because you want to see the hands and
what he's doing and it's just magical I
went with two people who are true magic
aficionados and they know all of the
card tricks
um and they couldn't figure this out a
couple of the things that he did out
it's really magical and fascinating and
it's an intense experience to you know
just have your mind blown close up
um so I highly recommend Ozzy wins Inner
Circle scour the internet for and
YouTube and whatnot for video of him
he's a phenomenal performer and uh it's
really delightful all right Peter what
have you been consuming I watched the
menu a smart mean funny satire of class
and high-end Cuisine so it's it's set at
a super fancy restaurant on a secluded
Island that serves only a handful of
very wealthy guests each night it's uh
it's 12 50 ahead we are told
um in the uh the opening sequence so you
can imagine how things go with a bunch
of rich people and a famous chef played
by a very sort of funny and dour refines
and a whole lot of knives and other
cutting implements
um and like stuff that makes fire uh and
meat right and it's the sort of movie
that like you know is driven by class
politics in a way that could have been
really irritating and really annoying
but in fact turns out to be quite clever
I just really really amusing and well
executed
um because the argument it makes the
main idea is not necessarily that it's
bad to be rich or that great food is bad
in fact the movie is very loving about
the way it presents the the food aspect
but instead it's it's sort of an
argument that snobs and esthets and
people who are not in into food for the
thing itself kind of ruin the art and
make it and and that making it perfect
and elevated to the point of joylessness
um is is something that sort of takes
the soul of it away both for the people
who should be enjoying these creations
and for the creators themselves and so
it's a really smart uh funny meditation
on class and uh you know and food and
art and like what it means to be an
artist and also what it means to be a
consumer of art
um and it's just a much better movie I
think than I expected watching the
trailers which made it look like it was
going to be this very sort of blunt
um and obvious you know class food
satire and it's it's a lot it's a lot
better movie than that a lot smarter
film
so a long-suffering listeners will
recall that uh I am engaged constantly
uh never-ending quest to do a couple of
things one is to find an appropriate
movie for family night
um not easy to do and the household such
as mine and uh and also to check the
boxes off uh Classics that everyone else
has seen and it's ridiculous that I
haven't seen it so far so in that in
mind can we take a moment to guess we
know because I was gonna oh I was going
to say uh we can take a moment to guess
uh Nick but since you uh interrupted me
and since Catherine uh she confessed the
answer I'm just gonna go straight into
it
um so the Christmas movie
that I finally got checked the Box off
on with the whole family except for the
teenager because come on
um but she would have loved it was uh uh
Tim Burton's Nightmare Before Christmas
um it's great people they're like more
of a Halloween movie yeah I mean that's
there's a there's an argument you can
start watching it in October and watch
it straight through the New Year if for
instance it comes out when you are 13
and it becomes your entire personality
for a minute just hypothetically
were you batting your big eyelashes at a
metaphorical Jack I mean
oh that lasted 30 years
I am to you having being able to see
that in a formative moment it was it was
definitely and it's like Tim Burton it
Tim Burton it's
it's and uh you know I I don't know that
I perceived it as a primarily an eyelash
batting activity so much as just like a
a whole
a whole aesthetic
if you like that movie I strongly
recommend Guillermo del Toro's new
Pinocchio which is also stop motion and
which is like a total like dead Heart
Like a heart-wrenching kind of situation
with Geppetto and his his you know his
the boy that he carves um but it's like
he's reimagined it as being set
um during uh the first part of the 1900
of the 20th century sort of as like at
the dawn of fascism because it's Del
Toro and it's a movie about how about
how being a parent is good and fascism
is bad
and it's beautiful
I will watch it but that sounds uh like
a terrible Matt how did your uh daughter
enjoy The Nightmare Before Christmas uh
the uh the seven-year-old loved it the
14 year old again would have loved it
because she's starting to get into a Tim
Burton phase
um and uh I loved it too uh for I know
that there are people who haven't seen
that movie because when I tweeted about
it uh Bill Schultz America's sweetheart
um said that he also has never seen it
because I mean I I get why you wouldn't
like it's a Tim Burton when that movie
came out was kind of he was he was uh
over saturating the culture a little bit
um actually uh fun fact not directed by
Tim Burton directed by Henry said that's
right there's some controversy about how
much Tim Burton deserves credit for that
um it is his uh Henry Selleck or selnick
is a really good director in his own um
there's uh Burton apparently had like
conceived of this when he was like
Catherine's age when she watched it or
something like that
um so uh this is a definitely a a a
flowering of his uh of his artistic
genre but it it is also for uh Danny
Elfman
um that was my big takeaway in addition
to just gorgeous and it's fun to look at
it doesn't make any sense it doesn't
matter
um but that uh the music is like almost
heartfeltedly uh elf menesque he wrote
all the songs he sings the songs uh that
Jack sings
um and as a uh someone who grew up in
Southern California in the 80s where
Oingo Boingo reigned to Supreme
um especially playing their Halloween
shows that they would play in Orange
County
um uh you could tell like he put He put
all of his heart and soul in The
Nightmare Before Christmas I haven't
seen every Elfman movie because I don't
watch Peter suderman's movies uh for the
most part uh but uh it's really great so
uh treat yourself if you haven't done it
before Nightmare Before Christmas you'll
be glad you did do it today
Etc
um okay uh this is nothing Elfman has
ever done will will beat his theme for
the first Burton Batman which plays in
my head every time I hear the word
Batman
[Music]
okay uh thanks for listening to The
Reason Roundtable podcast Matt uh do you
want to split a case of lemoncello now
you think I haven't been hitting it
already I I got I got the full
compliment right next to me right next
to the the baseball cards and the
keyboard
um okay uh listen to all of our podcast
at reason.com podcasts including the
recent interview with nicolespie which
sometimes is held in Speakeasy like
fashion uh uh Nick do you want to uh
pimp your next speakeasy
of all I could have pimped the last one
which was about decriminalizing and
destigmatizing sex work Matt which is up
online at reason.com in our YouTube
channel but the next one is January 4th
in New York and it's with Andrew
tatarsky a psychologist and therapist
and Maya solivas a journalist and author
talking about harm reduction as it
applies to drug policy Addiction
Counseling and actual use of uh
currently illegal substances it's going
to be fantastic go to reason.com events
and you can get information on the
recent species on January 4th I won't
tell you as is my costume usually to go
match the Donate button because you did
so uh so vigorously before we just want
to thank you for your participation in
the webathon which was a marvelous
results and uh and thank you for all
this it helps us do our work which is
really fun and great
um all right we'll get you next week
thank you and uh good luck and good
night
[Music]